hi everybody i'm josh welsh president
of film independent on what feels like
day 3927
of being cooped up at home i could not
be more excited to be here with you
to share our nominations for the 2021
film independence spirit awards 2020
obviously was hell on earth but one
glorious lifeline these past few months
has been the ability to watch so many
great films and shows
this year's spirit award nominees
inspired us connected us
and have been a source of urgently
needed light in
some pretty dark times so even though
we're all still stuck at home the time
has arrived
let's come together and celebrate all
the great work of 2020. three new things
to share with you about this year's
spirit awards first
we've introduced awards to recognize the
best of television that embodies the
independent spirit
the shows that we celebrate today
possess the same qualities
original provocative subject matter
uniqueness of vision
and diversity that our film nominations
do second
at a time when the country continues to
undergo a serious reckoning with racial
justice
film independent remains resolute in our
commitment to fighting for a film
industry
that looks like the world we actually
live in so when we talk about diversity
and equity at the spirit awards it's not
an afterthought or a side note but a
fundamental value that runs through our
entire process
this year of our nominated writers and
directors 57
are women and 48 are bipoc
and of our nominating committee members
who worked so hard to reach today's
nominations
67 percent were women and 63
were bipolar third and finally this year
the spirit awards will be broadcast on
ifc
not on the saturday afternoon before the
oscars but on the thursday night before
the oscars
thursday april 22nd 10 pm eastern 7 p.m
pacific one more note about the spirit
awards for
anyone who might be new to this the
winners of the spirit awards are chosen
by film independent members
film independent there you go
film independent is an open access
organization that welcomes film lovers
and filmmakers alike
no matter who or where you are on planet
earth if you care about great
storytelling
we want you as a member in order to vote
this year please join film independent
by february the 11th
you'll get screeners of the nominated
films and shows but most of all you will
be part of the community who decides
who wins the spirit awards in 2021. we
are so grateful for our spirit award
premier sponsor ifc
as well as fiji water the official water
of the spirit awards our sponsors make
the program possible as well as our
year-round activities
so for that we're we are so grateful
we're also honored to be partnering with
the association of national
advertisers see her the leading global
movement for gender equality and media
advertising marketing and
entertainment and amc networks to
further celebrate
and act as a catalyst for accurate and
meaningful representation
in storytelling finally i want to thank
the people who worked so hard
to come up with these nominations this
year we had over 40 dedicated filmmakers
and film lovers
who spent months on our spirit award
nominating committees
they watched and discussed over 650
films
and series fiction and non-fiction
american and international
that is a record by the way of the
number of submissions that we got this
year
in order to arrive at today's
nominations with that
i will stop talking i will go back to my
fiji water
but before i just want to say i'm so
happy to introduce
three amazing filmmakers who will
announce today's nominations
spirit award winners olivia wilde and
barry jenkins
and the one and only laverne cox with
that
olivia take it away thank you so much
josh
it is such an honor to be here to help
announce
the 2021 film independent spirit award
nominees
uh true to independent film i did my own
hair and makeup
i don't have any snacks um
and i the lighting is a little iffy but
you know we get it
in the independent film community we
make it work
we make it work and this year so many
incredible movies
have come out and we get to celebrate
them and i'm just so honored to be here
to help announce the nominees so i will
get started
best screenplay the nominees are
bad education minari
the half of it never rarely sometimes
always and promising young woman the
nominees in the category
of best cinematography the assistant
bull never rarely sometimes always
no mad land and she dies tomorrow
best documentary the nominees are
collective
crip camp dick johnson is dead
the mole agent and time best first
feature this one holds a very special
place in my heart because we were lucky
enough to win this last year for book
smart and it was
the greatest moment of my career and my
chair fell over and i was paralyzed with
shock and didn't know what to do
and it was amazing the nominees in the
category of best first feature
are i carry you with me the 40 year old
version
miss juneteenth nine days
and the sound of metal the nominees in
the category of best supporting mail
are coleman domingo from ma rainey's
black bottom
orion lee for first cow
paul racy for sound of metal
glynn turman from ma rainey's black
bottom and benedict wang from nine days
the nominees in the category of best
male lead
riz ahmed sound of metal chadwick
boseman
for mahrez black bottom adarsh
the white tiger rob morgan
bull stephen yoon minari
the nominees in the category of the john
cassavetes award
the killing of two lovers la lienda
negra
lingua franca residue
and saint francis and i am so
so excited to announce this year's
winner of the robert altman award
which is given to one film's director
casting director
and ensemble cast and the winner this
year
is one night in miami director regina
king
casting director kimberly r harden and
the incredible ensemble cast
kingsley benadir eli gorey aldous hodge
and leslie odom jr now to announce the
rest of these incredible nominees for
this amazing year in film i'm going to
throw it over to you barry
thank you olivia my name is barry
jenkins and this is chassis wong jenkins
and
we're here to present some spirit award
nominees to you
the nominees in the category of best
first screenplay
which i was not nominated for are the
assistant
lapsies miss juneteenth palm springs
and straight up congratulations to all
those best first screenplay nominees i
don't know what that feels like because
my first screenplay was not nominated
um i'm pretty sure that's true the
nominees in the category
of best editing what are the nominees
chauncey the nominees in the category of
best editing are
i carry you with me the invisible man
never really sometimes
always no mad land and residue
the nominees in the category of best
international film
are baccarao the disciple
night of the kings preparations to be
together
for an unknown period of time and
quabaitine's
ida the nominees and the category of
best supporting female
are alexis jacasedy from mr 18th
han yeri for manari valerie
mahaffey for french exit talia ryder
foreign sometimes always and jung yoo
jung
for manari the nominees in the category
of best female lead
are nicole buhari miss juneteenth viola
davis mahrez
black bottom sydney flanagan never
rarely sometimes always
julia garner the assistant francis
mcdormand
nomad land and carrie mulligan promising
young woman
the nominees in the category of best
director are
lee isaac chung minari emerald fennell
promising young woman eliza hitman never
really sometimes
always kelly reichert first cal
and chloe zhao for nomad land and the
nominees for
best feature film are first cow
marines black bottom manari
never rarely sometimes always and no mad
land
and now from myself and chauncey over to
you laverne
thank you so much barry i'm still
waiting on that invitation to work
together
you know i'm serious i'll bring it for
you barry i'll bring it let's do it
i'll start with the emerging filmmaker
award categories
each of these awards recognizes emerging
filmmakers
who have not yet received the
appropriate recognition
the truer than fiction award is
presented to a talented director
of non-fiction features the finalists
are
cecilia aldorando director of
landfall elegance bratton
director of peer kids elizabeth lowe
director of stray the someone to watch
award honors a talented filmmaker of
singular vision
the finalists are david meydell
director of the killing of kenneth
chamberlain
ekwa insanji director of farewell or
more
annie silverstein director of bull
the producers award which is given to an
emerging producer
who despite highly limited resources
demonstrates the creativity
tenacity and vision required to produce
quality
independent films the finalists are
kara dritt lucas joaquim
jerry kim and now to the inaugural
television categories
the nominees for best new scripted
series
are a teacher
i may destroy you little america
small acts unorthodox
the nominees for best new non-scripted
or documentary series
are atlantis missing and murdered
the lost children cities so
real immigration nation
love fraud we're here
the nominees for best male performance
in a new scripted series
are adam ali
little america nico annan
p valley amit rahav
unorthodox harold torres
zero zero zero confidence
little america the nominees for best
female performance in a new scripted
series
are l fanning the great
shira haas unorthodox
abby mcanini work in progress
mai tre ram kershnen never have i ever
jordan kristen simone we are
who we are the best ensemble in a new
scripted series
is awarded to i may destroy you
ensemble cast michaela cole
papa essiado juarucce
appeille stephen white
congratulations to all the nominees
today
and remember only film independent
members
vote for the winners of the spirit
awards so to become a member
visit org and join today
and don't forget tune in on our new date
and time
thursday april 22nd at 10 p.m eastern
7 p.m pacific only on ifc
thank you laverne and thank you olivia
and barry
and chauncey and luna thanks you too
uh congratulations to all of today's
nominees
and remember only film independent
members vote for the winners of this
spirit awards
so if you'd like to do that and i hope
you do please become a member of film
independent
just visit filmindependent.org and you
can figure it out there
don't forget tune in our new date and
time thursday
april the 22nd at 10 p.m
eastern 7 p.m pacific on ifc
with that thank you all so much and uh
look forward to seeing you soon
you